Sie gilt als Kinderstube der Kegelrobben.
Ich besuche die Insel Helgoland, wo jedes
Jahr Hunderte Jungtiere geboren
und aufgezogen werden.
Es gibt in der Tat nur wenige Orte,
an denen man den Kegelrobben
so nah kommen kann wie hier auf Helgoland.
Und die sind wirklich viel süßer, als ich
gedacht hätte,
aber auch viel gefährlicher.
Ich bin gut zwei Stunden mit der Fähre
unterwegs,
bevor ich Deutschlands einzige Hochseeinsel
erreiche.
Helgoland galt einst als Seeräubernest,
bevor es im 19. Jahrhundert zum beliebten
Urlaubsziel wurde.
Doch ich bin nicht angereist, um die roten
Klippen
mit der berühmten „Langen Anna“ zu
besichtigen.
Mich zieht es zur Badedüne, wie die
Einheimischen die vorgelagerte Insel nennen.
Im Winter kommen weniger Besucher, dafür
aber umso mehr Kegelrobben.
Und ihretwegen bin ich hier.
Manchmal sind es so viele Tiere, dass
Rangerin Ute Pausch den Strand
zeitweise sperren muss –
um den Robben etwas Ruhe, vor allem aber
den Menschen den nötigen Schutz zu bieten.
Denn was hier so süß aussieht, ist das größte
in Deutschland frei lebende Raubtier.
Wir nehmen den eigens dafür angelegten
Dünenpfad.
Von hier aus können wir ungestört
beobachten,
warum die Tiere eigentlich da sind.
Von November bis Januar ist Wurf- und
Paarungszeit.
Als Wurfplatz ist es so attraktiv, weil
das sturmflutsicher ist.
Und das ist ganz, ganz wichtig für die
Auswahl eines Wurfplatzes.
Die jungen Kegelrobben sind ja erst mal
darauf angewiesen,
dass sie mindestens drei bis vier Wochen an
Land liegen können.
Und das zählt.
Aus nächster Nähe kann ich verfolgen, wie
die Jungtiere gesäugt werden.
Nach zwei bis drei Wochen lässt die Kuh ihr
Junges allein.
Dann sind die Kegelrobben auf sich gestellt.
Obwohl sie alle relativ gleich aussehen, gibt’s
ängstliche, gibt’s welche,
die gleich auf Krawall gebürstet sind,
die immer unfreundlich sind.
Es gibt welche, die gucken sich alles in Ruhe
an.
Also vollkommen unterschiedliche
Charaktere.
Nach einigen Wochen unternehmen die
jungen Robben
ihre ersten Schwimmversuche.
Aber erst, nachdem sie ihr erstes Fell
abgelegt haben.
Das [Die] weiße, so kuschelig aussehende
Lanugo
bietet im Wasser nicht genügend Schutz.
Mehr als 650 Jungtiere sind diesen Winter
hier zur Welt gekommen.
So viele wie noch nie.
Schon zwei Wochen nach der Geburt sind die
Weibchen wieder paarungsbereit.
Die Bullen sind zu der Zeit besonders
aggressiv.
Die bis zu 300 Kilogramm schweren Tiere
kämpfen um die Gunst der Weibchen.
All das kann ich hier beobachten.
Direkt am Strand fühle ich mich an der Seite
von Ute Pausch sicherer.
Der Größere ist auf jeden Fall ein junger
Bulle.
Ja, leider
ist er gerade dabei,
ein Jungtier zu … begatten zu wollen.
Die wirken niedlich, aber sie sind es nicht.
Jetzt weiß ich auch, warum man 30 Meter
Abstand halten soll.
Also, ich mein, die beißen dann, oder wie?
Die beißen, ja!
Also, ich würde sagen, so ein Bein von
unserer Sorte
kann da einfach durchgebissen werden.
Ehrlich?
Ja!
Nach der Aufzucht- und Paarungszeit
verlassen die Robben nach und nach
die Insel und sind nur noch vereinzelt zu
sehen.
Bis zum nächsten Winter.
So viele Kegelrobben hier
in der freien Natur zu erleben,
ist wirklich beindruckend,
vor allem die kleinen Babys, die sind wirklich,
wirklich süß.
Aber wenn man denen so nah kommt,
merkt man, dass es in der Tat
supergefährliche Raubtiere sind.
Und deswegen schaue ich mir die lieber aus
sicherer Entfernung an.
Da ich auf das Streicheln
aber nicht verzichten will,
habe ich mir von meinen Töchtern
ein echtes Kuscheltier ausgeliehen.